alright guys I've got Ryan here we got a
whole bunch of stuff to talk about
we're gonna go real fast and furious I
think as I said to get through it all
thank you so much for coming thank you
for having me this is long overdue it is
we we had a scheduled one time and then
you had like this really important event
happen you can you can get into that
later if you want which one your second
baby oh yeah that was pretty important
yeah yeah that I I'd say that was a
milestone all right all right so a lot
of babies the the company's a baby
two-year-olds a baby that's all babies
baby background real quick for those
they don't know
sure so I started my career in venture
capital got into Bitcoin in 2013 and
really just started as an independent
analyst accidentally because when I
bought Bitcoin I'd been following it for
a couple of years but when I bought it
in mid to late 2013 it was right after I
Fred Wilson and the Winklevoss twins had
kind of come out so you know became
clear that this was not just gonna be a
tool for kiddie pornographers and
terrorists and and all that and then it
immediately went up six times in the
quarter of and the course of just a few
weeks you're great you're a great
investor for that oh yeah as well I mean
if that happened last year I would have
been a crypto fund manager but at that
point I was winding down my previous
startup so I came at this from the angle
of you know buy sell hold like how am I
gonna sell this and just chalk it up as
a win and then you know use that to
cover rent I ended up going down the
rabbit hole in a long weekend and I
think was like Halloween weekend of 2013
and decided I was just gonna be all in
on this and it was really where I
thought I might be able to spend the
rest of my career
so I sold what every good finance
professional should do I sold by 401 K
and took the penalty he's half of it to
buy more and then the other half used to
pay rent you're gonna love this so
there's a video that has never been made
public I'm not gonna tell you who has it
but it's of me saying if Bitcoin was a
$3,000 for
case gone I'm going all in the hall man
so I'm putting that on the record now if
it happened I hope we don't I'm part of
me hopes that we do and then the other
part is it's very painful we'll see the
85% a lot yeah but because that was 23rd
so okay so twice if I get in right
during the first bubble and then broke
the MAL [ __ ] story in short order
because I was writing a daily email
newsletter much like you really started
a build your following and I got to know
mostly executives and then for better or
for worse with that story you know still
maybe one of the biggest in the
industry's history everybody knew who I
was overnight even though I was just
this you know 28 year old kid that you
know really didn't know anything yet
still don't but one of the people that I
got to know is Barry Silbert s' joined
ECG before was DSG's the first hire kind
of a skunkworks employee at second
market helps recruit the core team we
raised a large round of funding in the
doldrums of 2015 and I was helping with
seed investing given my background but
before you go on in order to talk about
this for a second what was the general
pitch right so 2015 did not allow the g
pitch just to recruit people right so
there's not that many people who really
know about crypto outside of you know a
small subset of the population I'd see
I'm covered by CNBC I actually it wasn't
exactly like that because there were a
lot of people that got hooked
intellectually in 2013 during the run-up
during this what was the second bubble
but yeah yeah and so you know and then
everything crashed and and you know
there's a vicious correction so a bunch
of people washed out but the people that
like this happened in every single
Bullen and boom and bust cycle like some
people stay at that point though there
were no business jobs right there was no
way for you to do this full-time and get
paid to you know kind of scratch the the
crypto itch because the industry was
just so so much smaller and the only
people who were getting jobs were were
the developers right and there were only
a few funds right it was like us pantera
blockchain capital yeah maybe a couple
of others but that was pretty much it
they're all small
time to write obviously now you know we
kind of take free here about another 100
you know
million dollar fun every other week it
feels like which is great right because
there's a lot more talent that that's
coming in that's fundable but but still
it was it was much different so it was
it was actually pretty easy to find
people that were of like mine that were
really really excited about it so you
know obviously you know meltem joined
very very shortly you know after me and
and then you know Travis a few months
after that but but you know when I
joined I said you know I don't really
want to just be cutting seed checks I
just started a company and it didn't
work out but I like to be on that side
of the table so as soon as we close the
fundraise coin desk came up for sale I
was like ah this is perfect because we
were thinking about doing a large events
and you know I had this vision okay we
could do like the money 2024 for crypto
and coin desk had you know phenomenal
beta run and in the consensus 2015 event
it was a single day event here in the
time center New York Times building
right here and right at Times Square and
you know we said well we'll buy the
business will restructure it will bring
the team over here to New York and we'll
use basically the coin test brand almost
like is our top of the marketing fall
for the events and so between that and
then the DC G Network and all the
portfolio companies we had we were able
to throw fuel on that fire and over the
course of the next couple years you know
grow the events itself about 10x and got
the business to profitability and and
now they're off to the race I mean this
year they're gonna have a monster year
so that was coin desk those guys are
doing great I think most seem still
there which is good i I took a
sabbatical last summer after coin desk
and you know just trying to think what I
wanted to do next
started to go down the etherium rabbit
holes there is they're they're there for
anything that's built on top of a
theorem or is it all just like pyramid
schemes and and kind of get rich quick
ism which you know directionally was was
not an incorrect bet but my you know
through the process I pretty quickly got
excited about the potential even if none
of the assets themselves
we're super attractive at that point it
was just you know I made the comparison
okay bitcoin was like the central bank
of the new technological era and ether
is the new investment bank because it
didn't take off because people were
using it for distributed applications
they took off because it was becoming a
reserve currency for ICS so the first
thing that I try to do is just
understand the supply dynamics of some
of these assets and you'd go down the
top-10 on coin market cap and you
couldn't figure out what the circulating
supply was for you know these half
billion or you know multi-billion dollar
currencies that were in the top ten I
mean even even ripple even you know yes
and and and some of these other larger
ones you have no idea how much is
actually held by third parties and how
much is held by the founders and the
code is the the thing I was so
interesting every day was I think of
last year when corn market cap basically
changed some of the data right they just
said look we care if they said they were
counting incorrectly or these new data
set are clean the data or whatever they
did that graphs in our pitch deck yeah
which is the need for better day and you
know I I'm actually very quick to defend
coin market cap because you know we've
been you know in the thick of this for
the last you know 14 months now trying
to figure out like how to how to produce
better data for the industry
I mean well you know i'm sure go through
the full Masari pitch but it's it's not
easy because there are standards from
the exchanges they actually do a very
good job I was gonna argue that everyone
still uses it right and so yeah that's a
very little secret all everybody uses
quite market cap right you know we I you
know luckily we're able to wean
ourselves off of that you know pretty
quickly I think we're still in process
but for like the long tail of assets you
know they're still the only game in town
so for some of the major assets you know
and some and for some of the exchanges
that actually a very clean documentation
but I mean that's what that's a big lift
what they've done so now there are
others us included that are you know
starting to put this together and and
and you know hopefully up the standards
it's going to take a lot of time and
energy in between you know them and us
and guys like no mix and and and so on
you know better solutions are coming
which is good but you know the the the
kind of core thesis behind Masari was we
had to actually uh sure in an era of
transparency from the projects
themselves because so much of the really
material data about these new assets by
definition were only gonna be known by
these token sellers because of the
reserves because the founders rewards
and the vesting schedules and and you
know what restrictions they put on
resale for any of their pre ico
investors that's a lot of hidden
inflation in the system and we were
trying to model that out dan McArdle my
co-founder and I and and you know I had
written a couple blog posts on the
subject and he deems me we'd work
together previously we funded one of his
earlier companies at DCG and he says you
got to check out this the side project
that I'm working on I need something
like four on chain effects and I think I
called him like 15 minutes later after I
looked at it I was like this is amazing
like we're gonna start a company
together like we do this this it's like
hey that sounds fun tap the brakes you
want to get coffee but the rest is
history right so little did he know oh
yeah but but I mean it was like same
wavelength what he had already put into
code you know I was banging my head
against the desk trying to put in Excel
and and I think that the marriage really
worked out because unchain was the front
end but we both talked about and he said
the ethos of this industry is not going
to just allow another Bloomberg another
walled garden of data to emerge you're
gonna need some base data layer and some
common standard that people can access
so we decided we were gonna build an
open data library I'm sorry and focus on
disclosures from the project's
themselves and then you know on a more
proprietary basis we would do the Marcus
data integrations and you know actually
spin up these nodes for the different
networks and and parse blockchain data
and then you know progressively over
time pull more and more proprietary info
but certain information like who's on
the team yep what's your [ __ ] website
like what's the circulating supply like
that's kind of table stakes for for an
industry even as as nice
as crypto right you want to know that
information and that shouldn't be behind
a paywall
that's that's like front of an S one I
was most of the information that becomes
public in the non crypto world is
through the S ones right and so all of
the things you just described in terms
of you know what's the cap structure
what are some of the lock ups right so
this hidden or harder to get information
naturally comes public through
disclosures yeah of the the public of
the IPO process and and and this is
tricky because you know the SEC
obviously thinks everything is a
security and and many like many of the
processes they did look like securities
offerings in terms of like how they were
sold ok these tokens weren't useful when
they were sold bla bla bla obviously
people were speculating like crazy we
don't think that most well I shouldn't
say most we don't think that many of
these tokens that we look at on a
day-to-day basis structurally our
securities like we just don't agree with
that but there's existing precedent and
if it looks like a duck quacks like a
duck walks like a duck you know the SEC
is going to say it's a duck but you know
as we think about disclosures and and
how we can actually bring some
common-sense disclosures and
transparency to these assets let's start
with the extreme who speaks on behalf of
Bitcoin who speaks on behalf of no you
don't have you're not followed on
Twitter by the Bitcoin CEO I've got like
six of them following me oh yeah well I
mean aside from those guys of course so
and the SEC has even said right like you
know ether probably not a security
anymore which implies maybe it was
central so if that seed has already been
planted there's probably continuum and
what one of the things that we're trying
to do because we do believe in the
future of this ecosystem and many of the
assets that haven't even emerged yet but
that will emerge we're trying to make
that path a little clearer and if you
think about the regulatory mandate that
most securities regulators have they
just want to protect investors and
promote fair initial markets and and
ultimately you know facilitate healthy
cap
formation all of which you know has been
missing in crypto but is starting to get
a little bit more tightly wrapped
absolutely it would be fair to say that
masari's Masari I'm sorry
Italian Masseria I'm sorry look you're
gonna like really confuse me now no I
just I just wanted to guard time no but
it is my sorry if you can see him see
him sitting here saying this to me with
his Starbucks cup you would just be like
go home but is it fair to say that the
goal here is transparency of data or is
there some other way that you know may
describe it well our mission is to
promote transparency and smarter
decision-making in the industry okay and
it's always been those two things right
so on chain effects was always this
fundamentals oriented investor tool hmm
Masari was all about transparency
because you need certain inputs to get
ya puts the original are gonna be like
fundamentals right so yeah so we think
about okay if we're gonna be the one
setting some of these data standards how
do you do that without some government
or or regulatory body we're self
regulatory body that comes and has some
type of enforcement teeth to make those
rules what do you think the answer is
well we're gonna talk about toking
curated registries I'm sure and let's
talk about Amar'e's yeah so I think you
can use economic incentives and you're
talking about the economic incentive can
drive a enforceable disclosure a
collection of people to all follow the
same rules and actually have some sort
of we take that we call it we call it
the crappy data chasm right so so
earlier this year we launched a gora
which is our open library that we have
200 plus community analysts contributing
and crypto asset research into that
looks a lot like crunchbase the problem
with CrunchBase is that the information
is static and that's fine for private
markets because any new venture investor
is going to do their own due diligence
and ensuing round in crypto you have
private market information asymmetries
in public market liquidity so you need
events driven disclosures and you need
to find a way to level the playing field
but there is no top down
regulator that can globally enforce
these standards because these assets
trade across borders by definition so
you're not gonna have a global
equivalent of the SEC at least not one
that really works and self regulatory
bodies only work when they're actually
sanctioned by a regulator right now fed
FINRA with the SEC NFA for the CFTC and
those are like 80 and 40 years old
respectively the regulators so without
that type of teeth how can you actually
hurt cats and create some economic
pressure on projects to abide by
event-driven disclosures and and and
some type of common standards so that it
the quality the data that's in those
libraries doesn't just agree over time I
don't think a lot of people know when
you say event-driven disclosures
describe what that means if a if you're
selling off your token Treasury if a
co-founder leaves yeah so specific if
there's an actual if there's an actual
partnership that you're gonna announce
that that is real and it is not just you
know marketing fluff you know those are
things that move markets and if you tit
and and you know it's very easy in fact
it probably happens all the time people
get tipped off on any you know major
announcement and you see this you know
it's very difficult to prevent insider
trading that's why you know coin basis
and they're trying to do things as close
to the you know by the book as possible
and try and do things the right way and
and even still you'll see some of those
assets they announced a new listing a
few minutes before it's not much like
it's impressive how tight to the vest
they've even gotten much much better
they've gotten much much better
but it's still you still see like in the
in the minutes right you see some action
so like you know how do you prevent that
so we're trying to get closer and closer
to leveling the playing field and and
how do you create one common data
library where everybody would have
access to that information at the same
time so we said we're going to build
this open source we're going to build
API sit allow anybody to freely access
this information including maybe our
direct competitors for some of the you
know others you know SAS solutions that
we offer and ultimately we shouldn't
even be governing this open source
system so one
a that you might be able to create some
urgency and and and consistency of
disclosures would be to create a
registry of provably transparent
projects and if you had them actually
put up some financial stake and they
broke the rules then they put it off the
registry loser stake and you know mm in
the long term if you can actually
bootstrap that credential on the market
deems it as valuable and exchanges use
that banks use it as a seal of approval
if you don't have we're not gonna do
business with you
then it becomes something that's that's
kind of really powerful and because you
actually have money locked up in the
system you can incentivize a third party
validator set like kind of like a big
four accounting firm but on a global
scale or even just incentivize
whistleblowers that you you now have a
pool of financial incentives that would
encourage people to do the work to make
sure that projects are being legitimate
and and they're following the rules of
the system if you and I have a project
and we're interfacing with this and
we've got the economic incentive that is
staked we do something nefarious and we
lose that we egg booted out do you think
that because I think if it's kind of a
carrot and stick and the stick is the
incentive or the economic loss or is it
the ensuing reputational impact that
comes from the economic loss there's a
bowl today it's probably just the
economic loss okay because if you can
build a network effect around this and
it hits scale then it becomes
reputational loss got it because it's
basically saying it I'm trying to get
like a comparison but it's you know like
listing yeah D listing off a stock or if
you're some sort of you know bad actor
or something from raising capital or
whatever got it okay um where are you
guys today right in terms of what you've
got built
you guys just launched the the new
website and stuff so kind of walk us
through the product offering as it is
today and then kind of let's just touch
on how you see this evolving over time
and what work you have ahead of you sure
so you know I've always been a firm
believer that data without any type of
context is useless and you know
narratives without any type of data is
also equally useless and we've got a lot
of industry on both sides right
get off Twitter yeah I've taken I've
been on diet Twitter so I go on every
once in awhile but I've been trying to
try to limit my intake you know I I
generally think that we're coming at
this from three angles so we've got
curated news research analysis very
tightly synthesized and tagged and
categorized that it's easy to search and
it's easy to come up with a repository
of information if you're trying to get
smart on a person a project company and
so this is what I'll call third-party or
external media right so this is
everything when the Bloomberg the block
all these different media outlets that
are producing aggregated summarized
categorized and then you guys are doing
proprietary research and also some
summarized those yourself yeah I mean
I'd say that like our newsletter is a
synthesis of everything that we see on a
daily basis and it's you know it's also
you know primary marketing channel right
yep how do people find the newsletter
it's very good it's one of the ones they
open every day I'd write it above the
folds top of the homepage I'm sorry dad
I oh I see so you've got the I'm sorry
do you know the name mystery comes from
I do not this is fun so I said Masari
Ferrari so that's the way well it's so
it kind of plays off for the merchants
of Venice so the the Venetian merchants
were the ones that popularized
double-entry bookkeeping and actually
it's fascinating because of Franciscan
friar Luca Pacioli I was the one that
actually wrote down the Venetian
playbook for accounting and popularized
that and he was able to popularize it in
large part and it's stuck because for
the longest time merchants were not
exactly the most revered professions
right money changers etc and he kind of
changed that because he was able to
convince people that clean books was not
just good business but kind of a moral
imperative if you're gonna trust the
people who you're doing business with
and obviously you know that was a big
reason that we had a capitalist
explosion and the you know after the
14th century and the Renaissance I was a
great marketing ploy by him to change
the narrative there oh yeah
phenomenal right and so that's what
we're trying to do with crypto right but
instead of double-entry we're talking
about triple entry accounting using
these these public Ledger's how do you
actually parse them how do you build
standards around them my favorite thing
my favorite thing is the first time you
say triple entry accounting than anybody
in finance they look at you like you've
got two heads what the hell is the head
yeah and then they look at it I got a
pretty interesting yeah exactly yeah
maybe we wouldn't have had a financial
crisis or maybe the next one won't be so
much worse we don't know yet what we'll
get there in a second all right so let's
go back to the project itself so you've
got the new summary analysis so there's
dual curated content and then
quantitative con data which is markets
data and blockchain data primarily but
also you know other other bits of
information so that's how we really in
effects okay how do you get the
quantitative so if it's Marcos data it's
exchange integrations
okay pulling from their api's if it's
blockchain data we're spinning up around
nodes for all the major networks and
then you know parsing those data sets
and you know thrown them into a database
and running our own queries and then you
know over time I think we want to add
more and more data feeds so you know
there's a really interesting company
called hive that does Twitter rankings
but based on instead of like PageRank
that Google has it's kind of like people
rank so they do the rankings not based
on number of followers but on who you
know do you have really high Google
followers and vice for it and so like
they've created this this web so it's
something like that if we're talking
about people data then you know we'd
plug something like that in okay and I
think we want to continue to do that
with with you know very high quality
data feeds whether it's ours or somebody
else well the beauty of this is you're
taking a hybrid approach you can
integrate or you can build it out
yourself
and I'm guessing and builder by is that
you can the default is you're gonna
build it yourself unless they're
something that's better yes right it's
good way to think about okay all right
so you got qualitative data quantitative
data was a third and then there's this
disclosures library right so it's the
first party
disclosures from the project's
themselves and we kind of put that into
its own category because it's
as relatively static information it
shouldn't change too much but as soon as
we have it and we can you know
consistently go back and you know check
against it then you know we can build
software around it that that makes that
ongoing disclosure headache go away long
term so let's talk about this for a
second though you and I've got a project
we kind of do everything supposed to do
we put the disclosures out there they
know who the founders are what the
supply is when the Treasury you know the
whole nine yards when we go to let's say
sell some of the Treasury what how does
the product or other people in the
ecosystem know that we sold some of the
Treasury if we don't report it
you don't okay today yeah mmm the
incipio so one of the fields in our
application is what are your treasury
wallet addresses and then so we can just
look directly at the blockchain and you
pannacotta we will and check because we
have these nodes spawn up we will just
flag those wallets and if funds move
then we you know would send a ping to
the system and could reach out directly
to the project and say hey was this an
internal transfer was this a
distribution did you just do some type
of business deal where you had to
transfer this like what you know so this
is tagging categorize this is the fun
part about this entire industry right is
what you basically and and by the way
this is only this is only from the
project itself or like whoever is making
these attestation so you know no one's
speaking on behalf of the entire token
supply because once it's out its out and
that goes back to the comment I had
about you know these assets existing on
a continuum right hmm probably I'll
start fully centralized and look a lot
like a security and that's why we have
things like this aft long-term fully
decentralized that's at least a goal yep
and and and so if we can help in that
path should a projects we should there
be any person company entity that files
or you know does any disclosures with us
once the Treasury token supply is
depleted or an entity no longer
officially exists to control the
development roadmap probably not right
and so you could have projects that
no longer do any type of disclosures and
Masari not because they decided they
were gonna be opaque but because they
didn't have any stake like who's to
speak on behalf of a Bitcoin that kind
of thing
yeah it's funny because what you're
essentially doing is you're getting
people to opt in to a disclosure system
when there is a low likelihood of
nefarious activity right in the
beginning early when there's more
centralization everyone's gung-ho about
doing the right thing they're probably
fundraising or just fundraiser it can
all that stuff and then the longer or
the further you get away from that point
in time the more important it is
actually that they already opted it
right because now you actually are you
kind of got our hooks in and so if they
start to do things that maybe they
actually wouldn't necessarily disclose
you can detect something happened right
and kind of figure that stuff out I
wouldn't Owen frame it quite like we
have our hooks in right maybe this is
just marketing speak but no seriously I
mean that the projects that we're
working with so we're gonna announce our
first dozen or so the we could consensus
invest here in a couple weeks they're
all projects that are already pretty
transparent by design the issue is there
is no single place to host all that
information no one is representative
they would build an open-source project
out of something like this and truly
make this freely accessible to anybody
and really very few companies have the
the cloud or the distribution channels
to actually brute force something like
this a new existence I'd say by Nantz
right they they do have real clout
because if you want your token traded on
Finance and they tell you to do
something you know how high do you need
me to jump seesee right like that's
that's real the question is do you want
that owned by the largest exchange or
does that create an issue in terms of
monopoly of information and so I think
our approach to make this completely
open-source is is you know it's gonna
work whether we do it or we do it you
know with other partners and and you
know we can work on this together we
don't it doesn't really matter to us
because we're not making money on it
we're just trying to design the system
that will actually get this off the
ground and ensure that the in the
industry can continue to exist and
flourish and people don't go to jail
listen I I think people don't understand
or they don't understand yet how
important the work you guys are doing is
and I think over time it's gonna become
more obvious to more people so I'm chair
for you but thanks Bob
but yeah it's like the only nice thing
I'll say actually say that I was about a
couple of more macro type things in
crypto one you recently tweeted that
there's a issue around Bitcoin with
fungibility and you said that you were
overweight Manero explain what you mean
by all that and kind of how you think
about it then my co-founder calls this
the consensus contrarian portfolio which
is Bitcoin eath Monaro and z cash like
all the basically all the true crypto
currencies if you want to play that card
and you know I I've written about this a
number of times over the course of you
know many years the the thing that is
one of the things that's still kind of
scary about Bitcoin is they're not
they're not private right so with enough
forensics you can trace most actors in
the system and that's good for catching
bad guys that's not great for censorship
resistance and we already see kind of
anecdotally some of this behavior play
out where you know large institutional
buyers like in the past have gone
directly to the exchanges and and said
give us virgin coins and they'll pay a
premium because they don't want to have
to deal with all the the quaint ain't
who's actually owned it right has this
flown through Iran or some someone on
the OFAC shangkun's list and so if you
kind of zoom out if this asset class
continues to grow and grow and grow one
of the things that is a threat when
people use crypto even though we say oh
if you don't hold your keys like it's
not not your keys not your crypto most
people are gonna use the third-party
service right and that's the other dirty
little secret in the industry
everybody knows don't hold your Krypton
exchange but so many people do except
for like the stuff that you
this and this may be really calm for a
controversial but I act
but basically basically if that's the
system y-you have two types of coins
right and so they're not perfectly
fungible which is why I made the
statement about Manero I there's
definitely a lot of developers that are
talking about it but none of it but none
of the companies really are and and to
actually pull off incorporating
something like confidential transactions
or member one Bowl or any of these you
know cloaking features you're gonna need
a broad community consensus and some of
the regulated entities might just say I
don't know if we can do that because
that puts us in a pretty bad place we
can't use chain alice's we can't use
elliptic now and we can't you know
represent to regulators that were
surveilling you know potentially
suspicious so all by doctrine all by
that that the regulated entities are not
gonna be ecstatic about doing it but at
some point if you've got virgin coins
and non virgin coins and you get the
version coins into the hands of some
party over time the number of virgin
coins is going to decline until
eventually it could be zero right and
you end up with all non virgin coins
because they've all been transacted is
it something where you think at that
point it's just there's one bucket of
coins and it's all non virgin coins or
do you think that there's like a good
actor you know where you can actually
trace hey these are all good actors or
the KYC AML you know etc and then
there's the we don't know bucket I think
the issue is just with enough forensics
you can basically say these are
blacklisted these are white listed right
so you think that there could you think
that there could like let's take Bitcoin
for example there could be a separation
of good bitcoins and bad bitcoins for
you know for lack of better terminology
and some people will definitely avoid
the bad bitcoins yeah I mean you know
people were talking about this back in
in 2013 earlier right but yeah certainly
when I when I first got in how do you
actually should you be able to track
it's fascinating because US dollars for
it was that 70 80 % of the US dollars
have traces of cocaine on it right so if
that if you could label a physical US
dollar as good or bad you know how much
of the money supply would be affected
and put into the bad category yeah right
man
I always hear that stat it's fascinating
and I'm
use it I think everybody uses it I feel
like is one of those things that someone
just made up and then a bunch of people
said it and then it just I look I've
looked here's the visit isn't real is it
really true so he I've always used the
80% number and I look maybe this is
probably six months ago the number has
actually been decreasing mmm which I did
not expect likes do you would think oh
the longer period of time you know the
bills are in circulation so actually has
a higher probability whatever everyone
not doing heroin now alright so the
other thing I want to talk about is this
idea of influence in crypto right and so
there's a couple of different ways again
supply there's like the Twitter
influence was just how many followers do
you have who are they and and can you
get them rallied up to go do something
right or excite about something whatever
then there's like the hash Wars type
influence where can you actually get
people with computing power to go your
way when there's contentious hard Forks
all that kind of stuff and then there is
what I'll consider logo influence right
which basically means if you're an
investor in your logos on something that
must mean it's legitimate if you're a
news source and you wrote it it must be
legitimate right all that kind of stuff
those are three very different types of
influence but in crypto specifically the
impact of exercising that influence is
unlike any other industry in my opinion
right so if you look at if you can get
on Twitter a bunch of verified accounts
to tweet about a project the odds that
it becomes legitimate in the eyes of
people is really important and I'll use
it a direct example so Tron mm-hmm
there's a person who leads a project
with a verified account also that are
tweeting about it there's a lot of
people who immediately put more credence
to what the verified account is saying
about that project and let's say maybe
another project that has no verified
account as the creator of the project
mm-hmm how do we deal with it Rick is
what you're doing you're gonna have to
transparency the information but you're
talking about reputation scoring which
is just
you know mathematical way to do we
already do which is what can we do but
but assess brand quality and and
trustworthiness but but I think that
with the reputation scoring you've got
to get I will agree that you can move
markets much much faster in crypto at
least for now yeah okay with with with
you know things like just having a brand
and using some of those social cues but
I would argue that part of the reason
that's true is because there isn't
really good data in general and there
certainly aren't good data aggregation
or information aggregation platforms you
know and it's hard for the
counter-narrative to fight back because
we live in an era of fake news and
everybody you know like you know
everybody's opinion seems equal on the
Internet right so III don't think
reputation systems are inherently bad
like we we used those heuristics all the
time like the verified not verified this
kind of goes back to the token curator
registry example you know you want to be
on a list versus off you know we're very
good at making lists I like I always say
it I like the the token curate a
registry primitive because lists are
probably the one thing in this industry
as an application that's older than
money right like it's hardwired in our
DNA to be able to make like okay this is
the list of plants you shouldn't eat
like this is the this is the the census
of the village if you don't recognize
this person then easier to kill you look
like we're good at those and then you
know that you know that there's
intrinsic value to having certain
information and you know that you have a
limit on how much information you can
handle so you need those heuristics so
the question is how do we get better at
actually doing reputation scoring and
how do we make sure that people don't
get duped by a bunch of fake accounts
from an army' that's you know trying to
you know create a new world currency I'm
not gonna name any names you're smiling
ear-to-ear don't don't make me do it
what actually biggie is you know we're
talking about the reputation and very
cuz the easiest thing I think cuz it's
on a list of everybody counts or it's
not right but where I think it becomes
really
interesting and potentially dangerous
depending how it's used is you know we
just sat and watched the Bitcoin cash
like the fork of the fork I think you
guys called it right and it is some it's
like half popularity contest of like I
mean literally like high school politics
type stuff and then it's half like a
bunch of technologists sitting around
like really trying to figure out what's
better what's not how's this gonna work
etc and those two things clash so
violently in these hard Forks and
they're led by people and it's all about
influence I mean it is literally I
believe this person over that person and
I always think about the other day it's
like we're also at the stage where that
can happen because no one uses crypto
it's all funny okay explain this it's
all it's all game right now it's all
funny money over years know if there's
no fundamentals there's no underpinnings
no one uses even Bitcoin for
transactions that's that that's probably
the one exception like yes some people
are using Bitcoin in Venezuela in you
know dark markets right like okay that's
a single currency and still 99% of that
currency is just based on wild
speculation so of course narratives are
going to move the markets we've now
started to say holding is a form of
usage yet that's how bad it is right
yeah and it's not it's not entirely
inaccurate right beginning I gotta shore
up the monetary base rate I think this
is you know I actually believed that
there is regulation um--and
and this is the problem with all the
payment tokens and this how you knew
that most and we're gonna go down 99.99%
until they get all the way to zero well
you can't do that really with crypto but
but basically these these payment tokens
are completely worthless because there's
no reservation to man if you need to
actually use a payment token to access a
service you'll only hold it for as long
as you need to use the service which is
normally that's what second and then
you're out right so if you're just
converting in and out in and out and you
don't have any reason to hold any
working capital then it's it's all funny
money right and as long as people aren't
using the coin cash or even Bitcoin or
ether
and go down the list yeah then then
you're gonna have a bunch of people that
got paper wealthy ridiculously wealthy
from from this asset class though
they're gonna be able to throw their
weight around and make wildly outlandish
decisions about how to spend their money
and and and the game theory it's all
thrown off because these people have you
know more money than they know what to
do with and it's now just about he goes
I think the worst part about what we saw
the last couple days I can't imagine the
SEC approving an ETF this year I just I
can't no way not it's just you watch
like you gen not gonna name names
everybody can look it up but you just
watch those principles like going back
and forth it's [ __ ] embarrassing
and this is a multi-billion dollar asset
right so that if that's the current
state of things then you know we've
still we've still got quite a ways until
I have you can actually put this in
every unpopular opinion when it comes to
ETF it's dangerous it should be a little
bit harder to access I guess is my
general thinking I don't think the ETF
even goes like q1 like out like I could
see ETF being like another year away
right so we're you know oh yeah just try
q4 like it could be much farther than
the only the only argument I think for
the ETF is people if you're gonna drink
here if you're gonna drink do it here
we'll take your keys right it's you know
I guess that's the that's not a bad
argument right people are gonna
speculate with these assets would you
rather do it in a regulated more secure
vehicle that's got some rules in place
that make sense fair nuts that's the
argument for for back then fidelity and
and you know all these other big
legitimate institutions that are getting
into the space the other thing I could
see happened that Miss goes to the 3k
Bitcoin price I could see DTF getting
approved less a q1 and then we go down
50 percent right so basically the the
big moment everyone expects the ETF gets
approved then we're gonna be off to the
races and prices gonna recover
if for some reason the ETF gets approved
and it doesn't do that then what happens
I mean I I don't do price predictions
really I'm really bad at it forget price
prediction what I'm talking about is the
sorry maybe I missed the back half your
question because we just had microphone
issues was collapsing I just thought I
was having a seizure could be just like
slow-motion I think we looked at me like
he did something wrong I'm talking too
hard okay
so the ETF gets approved everyone thinks
that's going to be a catalyst for price
increase forget where it goes right but
just increase if an ETF actually gets
approved and then there's not a price
increase we go sideways or down I think
those are the types of moments that
really drive the capitulation and just
like like people psychologically don't
know what to do in that situation
because there's been so much time and
built-in expectation around that moment
right just because the TF gets approved
doesn't mean all the institutions start
buying absolutely and and you know
that's the surprising thing I think
people were surprised that there wasn't
more of a move on some of the news from
like ice his fidelity back yet Isis is
interested fidelity you know has a
service and there's gonna be more
announcements like that and the question
is you know is is anybody can actually
step up and start start buying and if
you just look at this from a momentum
perspective until the next rally starts
it's tough to see those institutions
just piling in for another major
institutional money managers are gonna
try to catch falling knife you know
market
oh I where it's personality-driven as we
just discussed I think there's a ton of
funds are shutting down I were in
November right now December by q2 of
2019 I think a larger number than we
expect the funds start shutting down
because the high watermark issue right
so basically they monetized in December
2017 they don't understand the economics
18 is gonna happen right umber 18
they're not gonna make the money they
thought
we're gonna make and then all of a
sudden why am I doing this it's gonna
take me other 18 24 months to come back
there's are shutting funds down and so I
think that it it could prolong bear more
colonel stuff before we wrap up I got
two more questions for you then you
could ask me one which scares the hell
out of me
but you wrote this blog post about how
people can get into crypto mm-hmm
explain your logic as to what people
should do if they want to learn get
involved etc well I was getting a lot of
inquiries on you know this isn't that in
the peak right December January and and
all hell was breaking loose so I started
to get just bombarded on Twitter and
LinkedIn and and you know a bunch of and
and like good intentions you know not
hey how do I make a quick buck like
people saying I'm really fascinated by
this header would break into the
industry and I just wanted to put my
thoughts on paper so I could just fire
off a link and and and so I wrote this
blog post The Apprentice crypto and and
it I just Lance where Faraday this if
this works I'm just gonna put this out
there maybe we'll get you know a handful
of volunteer analysts that will help us
populate some of this research in our
open data library and in it I said you
know I get these questions all the time
how do you break in you know my answer
is right about this industry every day
for two years for free and and then
you'll you know probably have a few good
ideas that stick during that time period
which is what I did and you know it's
kind of what you did
it's what Anna Carter is done it's what
Chris Byrne iski has done of Kyle's
money like if you think about like some
of the non engineers that have broken in
and just had an insane trajectory in
terms of how quickly they were able to
build their networks and followings
because the market is so wide open and
you know you're you're judged purely on
the quality of your ideas and kind of
consistency that's probably the best way
to stand out and that's that's the good
part of Twitter right so you know
leading into into my question Jesus when
are you going to write the social media
playbook for crypto people or are you
really really deathly afraid of losing
all of your
Lizzy herself I've actually tweeted
people think that I'm like I'm not open
to tell him actually you you remember
that I tweeted listen this is how you
win at Twitter and I I made a list and
it was point by point this is what you
do and here's the the two things that
are really interesting so one is there's
just some people who are better writing
than others right and so if you writing
does not just what words you use but how
do you construct thoughts and and and
kind of you know layer in and refer back
and do all this kind stuff so some
people really good at that some people
are horrible at it I think that your
idea of just writing makes people better
no matter where they are on the spectrum
but Twitter specifically there's this
quote that in the vault I think it's
enough all had it he was like you know
most blog post to just be tweets and so
literally when I first started like
taking Twitter seriously it was I have
all these thoughts of like oh I should
write something about yes and I would
never write it can I just distill it to
80 to 80 listen to any like right out of
the gate so you can actually write a
full sentence - so here's the secret
when 280 came out I was like that mom
yeah drop everything we could put below
its paces yeah so alright so mo talk
about all right let's talk about whoa
real quick and I do have a 1 a because
we were just joking about this before
but my 1 a would be what tweet do you
regret the most
oh ok actually it is but the the whole
thing around Twitter is that blog posts
you actually have to have enough
substance in order for people to
understand what you're saying you have
to have a point and you got a hat kind
of hammer at home to make it valuable
sometimes you don't have all that on
Twitter you can actually say something
that people find interesting not because
you hear my humble point but because you
made them think about something right so
you have more leeway and people kind of
interpret things different ways etc the
second thing is if you can show people
you're excited they get excited they
might not even know what you're talking
about
and so there's been a couple times I've
tweeted all capital letters WH Oh a
right at the beginning of this tweet and
I go down to another paragraph and I
type whatever it is and it says whoa and
people whoa okay
and so it's become this running joke now
that I've got a couple of friends who
they like I tweet whoa and there's no
whoa and then engage me but the tweet
that I I probably regret the most is I
don't regret it because I said it I
regret it because I actually didn't
write a blog post so this is one of the
flip sides uh normally I like the fact
that I just tweeted and didn't write the
blog post this is one where I wish I've
written a blog post yeah it's when I use
the terminal the terminology around
Bitcoin terrorists yes and here's why
that was when you took the break so
there pretty soon after that it was
right around toaster right yeah yeah so
I'd come out and I'd said listen if
tokenized securities work the way that I
envision them working tokenized secures
will be more disruptive on a global
basis than Bitcoin itself and the entire
argument was predicated on the fact that
if Bitcoin was to completely replace all
money right so actual fiat currencies
gold and silver it's like a ninety
trillion dollars or something right
global real estate alone is 215 trillion
so on a just a pure dollar basis real
put you know changing real estate and
completely ripping it out and having
this new infrastructure is more
impactful than money now
the Bitcoin Maximus came out of the
woodwork right they this was like the
most blasphemous thing they'd ever heard
and so both in private telegram groups
and on Twitter all of a sudden which you
got was the the propaganda machine yeah
right and I actually think most of them
have super legitimates I tend to agree
with many of the points that they said
now that I've spent more time with them
and they've kind of explained it etc
what just sent me over the edge was I
would say something so you know some
simple sentence and they would then
later on the thread refer back to what I
said with a little twist right now I was
like whoa I didn't say that and I would
go screenshot right now getting the
whole thing you know like this is what
terrorism is like it's propaganda
machine and you basically bully people
and you threaten and all stuff right now
that's a word that everyone knows look I
am it's a little it's a little loaded
I'm prone to the hyperbole right but it
was this is bad actually right if we all
act like this it is going to scare away
the people who don't understand that you
know the attrition of ideas and stuff is
a good thing right it's gonna scare away
the masses and so that's one where I
wish I had really taken the time to
write out hey here's what happened
here's why it's important here's why I'm
using this terminology and here's what
we need to do differently about it now
the funny part about that is most of the
people who are offended I've now become
friends with and they've kind of come a
little to the center of thought I've
come a little to center of thought are
you not friends with anybody I'm saying
that is it good I'm saying has a good
thing yeah but the best part about it
stuff to meet you in person it's tough
to meet you in person and not be like I
can't have a beer with top well I just
think that that's why so many people
like coming on the podcast if you're
positive yeah other people no matter how
much they hate how much they have
negative connotations on stuff you can
kill people with kindness I believe that
you I need to get better at that I I
just have way too many battle scars yeah
I have too much smart commute you'll
love this ready this is my girl was
gonna listen to this and she's gonna
roll her eyes to might go to the back of
her head right I texted her one day and
I said I hope you're having a great day
and she literally responded lol that's
what you tell the trolls on Twitter I
was like I've gotten myself into
did you just copy-paste it from like a
sweet I did that would hide it so much
better if you accidentally had like the
at somebody else and sent that whole
thing just as like a copy/paste job I
don't even good I was like are you
kidding me I've now gotten myself in a
position where I can't say that without
her thinking that I'm trolling her I
look man there's there you gotta have
too much of a good thing I guess listen
it's I'm long positivity short
everything else we're good to go
well makes it fun for your guests too
yeah look thank you so much for coming I
have to go watch the video because when
the one microphone fell that was pretty
epic will
we'll get a couple screenshots and
hopefully make a meme out of that at
some point all right they just felt like
I had to do that then he just did the
finger guns at the at the video so um
it's been a long week um I appreciate
I'm awful all right we'll do this
against me on that note maybe there will
be a part two Thanks thanks Bob